okay so big question what is the prize
splitting secret handshake yeah sure and
there is actually one uh really easy way
uh and if you phrase it like this that
that is the best way to do it and what
that is imagine this you're playing in a
32 player single elimination tournament
all you have to do is win five rounds of
magic and you will score yourself a card
where only four of them in the world
have ever been printed the expected
value of the card is around
$50,000 second place isn't even an
option anything less than first scores
you about $100 worth of product Against
All Odds you win three rounds out of
five and make it to the top four a
friend from outside the tournament comes
along and asks about buying something
called Equity of your potential first
place prize a judge happens to overhear
this conversation and asks what's going
on you promptly explain the situation
saying that you have no idea what your
friend is talking about the judge then
walks away and returns a few minutes
later to explain you have now been given
a match loss and have been knocked out
of the tournament well you don't have to
imagine too hard as this is exactly what
happened to Julian jackob Vitz at the
Gen Con secret lay Showdown event Julian
put up a message on Twitter saying just
got dced from the secret layer Champs
event after winning my match and
advancing into the top four owned 100%
of myself and made no splits with anyone
so I really got maximum punished
life-changing moment for me really
crushed the community was very quick to
jump and grab their pitchforks and
express their outrage especially towards
the judges of the event however this is
very much a similar situation to those
accusing Simon neelsen of cheating at
the pro tour those outraged seem to have
been misled and do not understand the
rules that govern this game and the
reasons they're put in place so let's go
over exactly why this outcome has
happened why these rules are in place as
well as working out what can potentially
change here to help me out with this and
answer some questions I have YouTube's
favorite magic judge Dave Elden from
judging for the win hi judge Dave thank
you so much for joining me today could
you please tell us a little bit about
yourself for those that don't know how
much experience you have in judging and
have you ever had to deal with any
situations like
this yeah yeah absolutely so my name is
Dave uh I'm from the judging for the
wind YouTube channel and I've been a
magic judge for a little over a decade
now and I have judged uh at every level
from a store level all the way up to a
Grand Prix level so the the smallest to
the largest tournaments uh that that
there are in Magic i' I've been judging
for uh you know all of those different
types of things and
I definitely have run into situations
where players have have wanted to
organize some kind of a prize split um
the place that I see it the most is uh
RC Qs I've judged hundreds of RC Qs and
uh you you have like the same sort of
dynamic there uh where the prize that
everybody really really cares about is
the the first prize where they get the
invitation uh whereas most of the people
uh you know don't even really care about
like the store credit or the booster
pack or whatever else is on the line uh
especially given that in order to keep
the costs down uh a lot of stores tend
to have like a lower entry fee uh and a
kind of minimal external prize pool and
people are mostly just playing for the
for the the top spot the
envelope now with this recent situation
at Gen Con we're hearing the words
bribery wagering and cheating being
thrown around are you able to clarify
the difference between these
infractions yeah absolutely uh so
wagering has like basically its normal
English word if you were to put a bet or
a wager on any portion of a magic game a
magic match or a magic tournament that
would be considered uh an instance of
wagering uh bribery has a very similar
meaning to its normal English meaning uh
if you try to offer any sort of reward
or incentive to somebody uh in an
attempt to influence their decision to
concede intentionally draw
make any sort of in-game decision uh or
if they're a tournament official you can
also bribe them and and try to change
one of their uh decisions they make in
relation to running the tournament all
of those would be an instance of bribery
and cheating uh is is kind of like a
catchall cheating is anytime you do
something that's against the rules with
the knowledge that it's against the
rules in the attempt to gain some sort
of an advantage for
yourself one thing I wanted to clarify
too we heard the words match loss and
disqualification and there seems to be
some confusion here is there a
difference between the two and what are
the
ramifications right so disqualification
is the strictest penalty that you can
get at a magic event uh basically if
you've ever dropped from a magic
tournament before a disqualification is
like that you're dropped from the event
you don't get any prizes uh and and your
tournament day is over at the point
where you get disqualified
uh a match loss is just that if you've
ever been at a magic tournament and lost
a match uh that is a match loss the the
judges can impose a penalty of a match
loss against a player and it will be
treated exactly as if that player has
lost the next match that they're that
they're scheduled to be part of and so
there are a couple of important
differences uh between those mostly
involving for example you would still
get any prizes that you would be getting
if if you are assessed a match loss uh
sometimes the the disqualification is
accompanied by additional penalties such
as uh a ban on playing Magic in future
tournaments uh a match loss is generally
not associated with anything like that
on the other hand certain tournament
structures uh especially ones that have
uh a single elimination structure there
is very uh uh much similarity between
those two because if you lose a match
then that also ends your day in that
tournament okay so big question what is
the prize splitting secret handshake
what is the best way to prize split
without getting a DQ or a match loss
yeah sure and there is actually one uh
really easy way uh and if you phrase it
like this that that is the best way to
do it and what that is is Judge I'm
interested in in a prize split would you
help me and the reason why it's
important to get judges involved is that
it is legal under some circumstances uh
to arrange for a prize split and the
problem is that there's some nuance and
some some uh
interpretation involved in whether
whether I want to to do a prize split
because uh I'm I'm trying to bribe my
opponent and I'm I'm trying to secure a
better amount of prizes for myself or
whether I uh want to do one of the
legitimate prize splits that are
actually Allowed by Magic's tournament
documents and the difference between
those two uh can be kind of uh fine and
sometimes it's up to the facts that the
judge is able to determine and the
judge's interpretation of the facts that
they're not able to determine if you get
the judge involved right away uh you're
going to be guaranteeing yourself that
you're on the the up and up now one
other uh kind of important thing about
doing this is that uh you don't want to
talk about what type of prize split that
you're uh trying to arrange until uh
after you're talking to the judge and
the judge will generally want to talk
about that away from the table because
if you say something like
judge I'm happy to ask my opponent to
scoop to me and give him $50 for it is
that allowed uh because if if your
opponent hears that offer uh then it's
really difficult for the judge to say
that they're not considering that offer
when your opponent is making future game
decisions right uh and so a lot of the
time the judge will require that
discussions like this be held away from
the table uh and you know only proceed
after the judge has said yes or no as
far as what it is you could or could not
say or
offer and just so we're Crystal Clear
what should you do if someone approaches
you and asks for a price split yeah and
so the the answer to that question is
exactly the same um you want to get a
judge involved uh as as soon as possible
because what can happen is if if
somebody offers you a prize split and
the judge thinks that you considered
that prize split or accepted that prize
split and it was not a legal one for you
to do uh the penalty for you is going to
be the same as the uh you know as if you
had offered that prize split yourself so
nice and clear when in doubt call a
judge yeah we're here to help and we
really do want to help judges aren't out
to to DQ people and in fact every Magic
tournament at uh I've been to
has had some sort of an announcement
from the judges uh once we get towards
the the big prize round uh that hey uh
don't get yourself in trouble be sure
you call a judge if you have any
questions about this sort of thing and
so uh at least the the events that I'm
familiar with we do try really hard to
to educate and Outreach for players uh
when it comes to situations like this
because we understand it's it's a high
Stak sort of environment there's a lot
of pressure involved uh and we want
everything to go smoothly just as much
as you do having said all of this and
with everything that has happened do you
think these rules are important to the
game and do they need to be changed or
updated yeah so there's one very
important reason why uh that that really
sticks out to me for for why these are
important uh which is that in a lot of
dis uh you know a lot of
jurisdictions if if you have uh an event
that could be considered gambling uh
miners are probably not allowed to take
part in that event and we definitely
have miners who want to take part in
Magic the Gathering tournaments and so
this sort of uh framework keeps
everybody safe now with that being the
case I I do think that this is one of
those areas of policy uh where I I I
think that the rules are around it are
not in the best possible place that they
could be but I think a lot of that is is
out of necessity uh and the fact that
the laws around this sort of stuff can
vary from location to location now now
with that being said I think the the
biggest thing that that magic and
tournament organizers could do uh that
that would help this issue is to kind of
get rid of this Glen Gary Glenn Ross
style of magic tournaments where there's
literally tens of thousands of dollars
in between first place and second place
I think anytime you have that much
incentive for players to try to work
something out uh you're going to see
players attempting to work something out
whether there's a a tournament policy
somewhere that says you can do it or not
excellent information any final shout
outs or plugs that you want to give uh
no I mean if you uh want to hear about
this or any other kind of magic rules
and policy topics in more detail you can
check out my channel I did a video on
this uh myself where I talked in detail
about all the different magic policies
so if you're interested in a a fuller
explanation then I recommend that you
would check that out thanks for that
judge Dave be sure to check out his
channel and give it a follow all of his
details are linked down below
okay so let's recap and go over a few
things first I think it's really
important to reiterate one of the final
things that judge Dave said MTG judges
are not out to get you judges want to
make sure the game is played correctly
and fairly and I want to stress that
last part as we'll come back to that in
a second second even though Julian said
they were disqualified they were not as
Dave mentioned disqualifications are
much more s
you are removed from the tournament
forfeit all prizes and it can end up
with the dced player receiving a
suspension or a ban while getting a
match loss in this case does feel like a
DQ it's really important to
differentiate between the two both
Julian and the judge report both
indicate that some discussion of
wagering had taken place without
discussing it with a judge first looking
at the infraction procedures guide a
match loss was the appropriate penalty
here to be fair I think Julian got very
lucky here Julian is a seasoned player
having won two Eternal weekend
championships they even mentioned in
their own statement prior to this event
many people that I knew were swapping
Equity with one another meaning that for
example one player would own 80% of
themselves and 20% of another player in
the top 32 and vice versa I had been
offered Equity swaps by many players But
ultimately decided to not accept any of
them because I liked my odds in the
field which obviously contradicts that
he did not understand his friend when
they asked about buying some of his
future card Equity the important thing
to note is that if you knowingly break a
rule that is considered cheating and
will end up with a disqualification
Julian and the judge report do both
mention that Julian thought he was
acting within the rules when discussing
this with his friend so I too would ER
on the side of caution here now this is
is exactly why this channel exists there
are so many rules in the game and I aim
to cover as many of them as possible to
ensure no one gets caught out by
anything so as far as what happens next
I think the main takeaway from this
video is that bribery and wagering rules
are extremely important to the game
imagine going to an rcq and hearing that
the person who won the event had their
friends conceited them for half or more
of the rounds meanwhile you're playing
by yourself through every single round
as Jerry Thompson put it we should be
taking a hard stance on collusion and
treating it just like cheating having
said that just like judge Dave mentioned
having a near
$49,000 prize difference between first
and second place doesn't really help
things here so all we can really do here
is make our voices heard in the hopes
that Wizards change something and now at
the very least we know the correct way
to split prizes with the current rules
in place what do you think of this whole
mess do you think these rules need to be
changed let me know in the comments down
below as always if you learned something
be sure to like the video and subscribe
because if you don't Jerry Thompson and
his crew are going to rock up to your
next magic event and Jerry will win the
tournament without playing a single game
of magic thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one